on avait organisé une course de règne à
les voir participer à la coudraie 12h04
n'importe quoi même une course de rennes
avec nous normalement il n'y a jamais de
problème à la sauce avec l'équipe ne
touchent pas où on a failli passer à
côté d'un drame à ouïr garder ses formes
à 6
[Musique]
on a connu pire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le tapis
mais aviva sigfried des trucs juges
concluent par là vous avez us s'échange
vu les reds
[Musique]
bon remettez-vous là quand vous allez
bien vous le voyez pas mais il est 11
heures du matin
ici je serai peut-être de ma mère c'est
une boîte de nuit tout le temps mais un
héros max au max ca du jour j'ai fait un
truc darren law
donc ce n'est pas longue les chéris j'ai
des bonnes et des mauvaises nouvelles
avec des bottes la bonne nouvelle c'est
que vous allez conduire un traîneau avec
des reds à rennes à rennes qui fera un
parcours dans la forêt c'est
exceptionnel
mahmoud a voulu faire merci cyril la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'il y en aura
que quatre qui vont faire ce périple
aller faire une course pour choisir les
quatre personnes c'est très simple je
vais faire ce que j'ai toujours fait
sinon voilà exactement car j'ai dit que
c'est un tirage au sort pas possible
cela vous serez 2 duo 4
car tu veux pas fermer ta gueule pour
trouver le premier duo vous allez tout
fait votre main derrière votre dos
je partirai de maxime kenny jeux fra
calcul ce sera le premier sélectionné on
va commencer
enlevez moi beaucoup parce que sinon tu
vois par rapport à ça ben si vous avez
des mousses comment tu mens je vois
trois deux un top-5 plus de 7 + 3 10 12
14 14 et 4 18 voilà enfin une espèce de
chifoumi il faut faire des chiffres y
compte bon ça n'a aucun sens à son cyril
d qui sort des règles on comprend rien
et à la fin ils gagnent toujours et on
perd toujours 3 2 à 4 6 9 9 + 5 14 mai
14 sets 20 25 27 1 2 3 4 25 26 27 ans
qui va faire maintenant
lorraine non les vidéos c'est le binôme
de gilles pourbaix refaite et je
démarrais de quelque 3,2 à moi j'ai déjà
gagné mais là on va savoir avec qui je
suis tout sauf maxime est tout sauf
maxime s'il vous plaît 23 24
c'est bon je pense que pour des
questions de sécurité
on va faire une fille un garçon comme
alors on va faire on va faire comme vous
voulez la sélection
et les plus sûres de cannes la route est
droite sait jamais il peut avoir à by
kanye sait que c'est mal entendu bon les
chéris vous allez partir dans la forêt
le seul où il est dans ses bougies alors
tu vois quelque chose que je vote a une
sale gueule ça c'est pas bien saisi
vous allez partir avec chacun un
traîneau avec un règne que vous allez
choisir dans un instant et vous allez
donc piloter dans la forêt réservoir un
parcours il y aura des cadeaux
il faudra attraper les cadeaux sans
s'arrêter d'accord ils sont sur les
côtés et ça il y en a un qui conduit
ainsi sa défaite vous verrez c'est pas
non plus ça va pas non plus à 200
kilomètres/heure je vous la passe est
manquée je vous le dis vous allez
conduire ses rennes mais nous dans
l'émission on a toujours eu notre règne
notre reine des neiges au majorat
castaldi vous serez bien sûr en val des
neiges et vous devrez chanté pendant
tout le trajet libéré délivré avant
avant bazar
adam bâ
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est partis pour une course de rennes
ah oui alors les quatre sélectionnés et
ekedi benjamin gille écart ou alors
normalement ça se passe toujours bien et
malheureusement avec nous rien ne se
passe comme prévu on a failli passer à
côté d'un accident terrible oui quand je
dis terrible c'est terrible c'est
terrible - vous avez eu peur où vous
allez ah oui alors je veux pas dire que
j'ai peur j'ai eu peur pour eux parce
que franchement je maîtriser la
situation
comme à laquelle ou quoi même deux mois
ce marais puis à braver l'arrêté sur
marilyn c'est vrai c'est vrai ce n'est
pas ce que j'aurais peut être
extrêmement oui
ah oui oui bah je vous dis regarde
[Musique]
allez vous êtes prêts à desserrer oui eh
ben on va les cueillir la reine des
neiges voilà la reine des neiges sari
avec mon benji m'a dit monsieur beauté
magnifique regard des communes regardez
comme les baux revenir à une part
landaises ont fini les conneries
maintenant j'ai envie de commencer ma
course avec mon rennes et celui-là je le
sens bien je suis sûr qu'il est hyper
sympa comme mon père douze mois gardénia
doucement égard doucement doucement
égard doucement j'ai des gars du tarot
doucement de gargar doucement doucement
et nerveux
bon d'accord égard il a son caractère
comme moi attention 3 2 a porté le
départ en fait est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus tôt n'est que je pensais
pas ce que ça sa part super vite et en
plus je perds caroline goût de 2,5 m le
renne s'emballe ça qu'on fait contraire
à ce qu'on pense ça va très vite un raid
ça va très très vite ses côtés c'est
comme ça comme un cheval donc on va à
fond la caisse
et là je suis en fait dodo parce que je
regarde où sont les cadeaux je me
retourne et je vois plus laïque de
gaulle à de vue qui est composé de le
traîneau et de l'ue a disparu donc lâché
en panique
le traîneau tourner à gauche donc je me
retrouve tout seul et je comprends en
fait que avec deux lieux aller soultz
haut plus on a failli avoir un accident
avec la cousine de valérie vais
d'ailleurs j'ai rien very inqiétude on
peut l'applaudir avant bras mais
attention be careful ldk foule 3,2 à
aller
[Musique]
nous avons corrigé au quick benamor
jolicloud
castaldi choc
[Musique]
m
d
[Musique]
young a annoncé
à bord
[Musique]
caroline ithurbide non nombre de cadeaux
mais comment ça c'est un scandale je
demande qu'on recompte les cadeaux on
recompte les cadeaux j'avais bien
travaillé je vous déclare les 2 duo
gagnant
on va voir la l'accident que franchement
juillet on a eu tort parce qu'elle est
passée sous le règne un moment on est
passé ça ça doit bien ça non mais
vraiment c'est une prochaine fois que ça
lui arrive allemagne et ensuite en 60
ans qui faisait la lumière sont jamais
c'est arrivé en corse fait bondir la
série ne sera pas que c'est ce truc là
pour gérer ça c'est pas cher il s'est
révélé à celle reine la reine des neiges
elle partait jusqu'aux sorties